my dear brothers and sisters may Allah
bless you all Subhan Allah
Daniel or the
devil Allah is exposing him more and
more so
recently has been doing live stream
trying to belittle to what took place
and guess our brothers sisters in Syria
by the hands
of the rafidi regime Iranian rafidi
regime and his allies killing innocent
people and uh uh children from Syria
that's why I've said it many times that
the rafida are utilizing and the dogs of
the rafida those who works for the
rafida and they defend the rafida and
they justifi disbelief and the paganism
of the rafida while they w a war and
guess those who call openly to
the and ref and and openly they will W
against the lik
ofi there's no other
than now it's just getting worse and
worse Subhan Allah and again this
another lesson from you for to know
alhamd when thef is speak speak with
knowledge and Justice alhamdulillah
because it is you cannot slander and lie
against people it's Haram you be hold
accountable for
it I mentioned it before he's a hidden
no he's not even hidden anymore he's a
dog of the Iranian rafidi
regime so that as you're going to watch
in one clip he's trying to tell our
brothers and sisters who were killed and
their fames been destroyed and the house
been destroyed by the hands
of advise another clip as you going to
watch when is lying and IM Alani
claiming that IM Al does not make on the
of the the sh and we can hear making a
clear
upon so my dear brothers and sisters no
one defend and support Daniel Hu
devil
except Who hat and he
loves and the issue of festine is been
used there by the enemies of Islam to
spread their misguidance but
alhamdulillah I've seen some clips which
makes you happy from our brothers and
sisters inaz saying to the ra stop and
the the enemies of Islam stop using our
uh suffering as a shield to spread your
disbelief and your paganism and your
misguidance and your agenda allahar may
Allah reward them and may Allah Aid them
and may Allah destroy the zist and those
who are helping them in private openly
fighting against our brothers and
sisters
in was making this Dua it was very hard
for him to
sayb because he knows the Iranian regime
in private they are aiding the zist
Allah look What's happen
now passed away been
destroyed ulated and Allah bring to kill
another the are Allah bring them against
another allahar then Allah will destroy
all of them allahar the another clip
when ly against sunnis and claiming that
the
sunnis believe some sunnis believe
Prophet Muhammad controls the universe
even the atom I don't know which sunnis
you know SAS are not sunnis if you speak
about those who follow the Sunnah they
are not for the sake of argument I say
they
areis anyone believes the messenger of
allaham control the
universe individually because it's no by
necessity That No One controls
everything except Allah
Subhan Allah so anyway my dear brothers
and sisters you will watch and there's
many many there's many brothers out
there exposing him
exposing allahar hiding behind the issue
phe
lying and anyone that
expose he will call so m is someone who
expose paganism and this believe and
support Sunnah and according to do
Devil is a big praise so now if someone
call you what it means that you are
supportive and refuting
and he hat it because you're going to
expose his
Masters my dear brother sisters and may
Allah protect the Muslims from the evil
of this individual
emotion okay that's you know unless
you're you know a certain gender then
the emotion is just the immediate thing
then after a day after two days after 3
days you sober up and you assess and you
realize what's going on but
unfortunately we have uh a lot of
estrogen addled
brains and they don't understand like
they don't see anything beyond the oh
heah has killed sunnis yes we know
despicable condemnable
horrific
horrific now
what no but they they'll never let you
get beyond that they'll never sunnis who
haven't forgotten what happened in Syria
though well I I I say that because
that's the discomfort that we have with
Iran sure okay so so my my my best most
most most kind of friendly way of
putting this is say get over it look I I
have a completely different
understanding what happened to C than
you do
right and you have even contemporary
Scholars contemporary caie Scholars
like
albani uh the Albanian scholar who would
not even make teir of their
imams even their ayas he would not make
teir said no you have to have something
specific you have to have something
specific that it's clear that they
believe and that that person that
individual Shia has expressed for then
it to be valid to make Tech fear of that
uh one particular individual
Shia and for
now the Shia today are much closer to
sunnis than Shia were a 100 years ago or
200 years ago there's been a sunnation
process of Shia in the past 50
years uh but a lot of the statements
that were made against Shia in the past
are no longer relevant because those
doctrines are no no longer held by the
majority of the Shia so these are things
that have to be understood and if you're
just blindly sectarian you can't do
proper research you can't properly
understand well what did the majority
of who is the bigger enemy Shia or
Zionist
explain it's just so shocking it's just
so even if you take this incorrect
position that all Shia arar like how can
you compare what Israel has done to
Muslims just in the past year to
anything that has been done by Iran or
Hezbollah or Shia like how are you that
dense like I'm sorry like I don't mean
to insult you but you are at a level of
ignorance about the situation that it's
you're just going to hurt yourself or
you're going to hurt others because you
don't you don't know what the reality is
you know that Israel has just uh
murdered over
200,000 Palestinians in Gaza over the
course of just 10
months 200,000 possibly 300,000 200,000
is the conservative estimate of how many
they have killed that is over
10% they've killed over 10% one out of
10 Palestinians have been killed what
where has Iran or Hezbollah done this
like if you want to look at death toll
in Syria or in Iraq over the past 10
years or 11 years okay take that number
does it extend to even 1 million people
no and I defy anyone to bring me actual
third party resources to justify that a
million syrians Sunni syrians have been
killed by Assad
but it could just be ignorance like you
think that oh the Shia they're all kafar
and you don't understand that that's
that's not a correct Tech fear that
you're doing like the kinds of
criticisms that you're making against
Shia they apply to many Sunni groups by
the way right um if the what are the
criticisms they say well you're a cfir
if you insult the sahabah okay there's
details in this by the way did you know
that insulting the sahabah doesn't mean
that you're automatically a cfir
according to
sunnism insulting the sahaba can't be
automatic cir status why because some of
the sahaba insulted each other so are
the sahaba
KU so how are you there are conditions
like what kind of insult is it is it
insulting all of the sahabah then yes
that is kufur and that will take you out
of Islam because it contradicts the
Quran and the companions of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in generality
are praised so if you are insulting and
denouncing all of the sahabah then that
is kufur because it contradicts the Ayah
of the Quran but that's not what Shia do
by the way that's not what they do e
it's one sahabi or two
sahaba that's not according to sunnism
and the of
of it's not automatically that you're a
cfir if you insult the sahab it depends
depends on the nature of the insult and
the who exactly you're insulting what
you're insulting them for